[music playing]
NARRATOR: Astrakhan Oblast,
Russia, 500 miles south
of Moscow, June 19th, 1948.
11 months after the
Roswell Incident,
at the Soviet military rocketry
research and development
base, Kapustin
Yar, erratic blips
appear on the radar screens.
At the same time a
MiG jet fighter pilot
sees an unidentifiable,
cigar-shaped object
flying in front of him.
What we have now
come to understand
is that there was an engagement
of the Soviet military
with an unknown object
that came into the airspace
at or near Kapustin Yar.
And the Soviet MiG fighter
was scrambled to intercept.
The aircraft engages
in a three-minute
dogfight with the UFO.
The jet was able to
fire off a missile.
And the missile
apparently hit the craft
just as the craft hit
the MiG with some kind
of blinding flash of light that
caused the MiG, with the UFO,
to crash.
[explosion]
When people talk
about UFO crashes,
they talk about
Roswell as if it's
the only time it ever happened.
But it's happened repeatedly.
Kapustin Yar is
another great example
of a genuine, Roswell-type
crash, this time in the Soviet
Union, and totally
classified under the umbrella
of national security.
There are special teams designed
to create a cover story,
and the wreckage goes
off to warehouses
in which that technology
is analyzed and understood.
NARRATOR: Rumors have circulated
for years that nearly a quarter
mile beneath the surface
of the Kapustin Yar base
are hallways and
chambers containing
downed extraterrestrial craft
and rooms where alien autopsies
have been performed.
RICHARD DOLAN: This is really
the Soviet Union's Area 51.
It was very, very remote.
The Soviets did all of their
major rocket testing, a lot
of their advanced
back-engineering of Nazi
technology from World War II.
This is a very, very
sophisticated place.
Some people came
up with the idea
that this was the main
storage of the crashed UFOs
in the Soviet Union,
and the secret tests
are being done there.
NARRATOR: Curiously, at
this secret facility,
the Soviets developed
better nuclear weapons
and delivery systems
in 18 months than they
had anticipated
creating in five years.
In 1959, the United States
Central Intelligence Agency
began to monitor the
covert base and collect
aerial photographs from a
U2 reconnaissance mission.
WILLIAM HENRY: When the United
States sent recon missions
over there during the
Cold War they looked down
and they saw these incredible
carved images on the ground
around Kapustin Yar.
DAVID WILCOCK: When we
actually look at the depictions
of these geoglyphs, they
look similar to what we see
in crop circles and in
certain ancient land
forms visible on Earth.
So there clearly appears to have
been an attempt to communicate
with the extraterrestrials,
perhaps saying,
x marks the spot,
come here, guys.
Kapustin Yar was one of
the former Soviet Union's
most secretive airbases.
The rumor is is they
were researching
UFO technology there.
And one wonders if it's
possible that those symbols were
in fact used to attract UFOs.